[Musique]
je pense qu'il y a une malédiction qui a
frappé toute la classe politique a
commencé par Bourguiba à se demander
s'il y avait pas une malédiction ou un
fantôme qui habite dans les sous-sols du
Palais de Carthage qui fait que tous
ceux qui entrent perdre la tête quoi
[Musique]
j'avoue que je suis content d'avoir été
reste d'avoir gardé l'anonymat pendant
la les années les dix années on va dire
de postes révolution aujourd'hui
l'anonymat devient tout simplement je
pense vitale parce qu'il y a un risque
comme d'ailleurs certains qui sont fait
arrêter à cause de leurs opinions des
fois exprimer sur Facebook dans que dire
de dessinateur qui critique jour et nuit
le président voilà l'anonymat est
nécessité
[Musique]
j'ai une dictature je pense et en plus
c'est un virage fasciste carrément nous
sommes dans une forme de fascisme
parce que sous benalli quand même il y
avait on va dire on entend des pas le
peuple le peuple avec qui mais je sais
pas ce que c'est vraiment le peuple mais
on avait l'impression que c'est le
régime que je critiquais là en est tombé
dans quelque chose de nouveau on a
l'impression qu'il y a aussi un soutien
populaire
[Musique]